is the goal of the local non-profits
save redrock they're trying to tweak a
few things around there while making it
safer for everybody the safe redrock
legacy trail would allow for better
access for bicyclists for runners
walkers now the first phase a five and a
half mile stretch from charleston and
sky vista just west of the 215 all the
way out to the red rock fee station to
get into the recreation area there's the
plan to eventually connect summerlin all
the way down to southern highlands and
some folks say yay that's a good idea
almost every major city america is so
car dependent and people are just now
going transitioning to like bicycling
you know skateboarding all of that stuff
i feel like it has to be addressed to
have more accessibility to people who
don't just want to see
you know gas guzzling cars as their way
of transportation
clark county commission recently
approved spending 4.7 million dollars
for that project you can weigh in on
that first phase until may the 9th
heather